[Music]
this week marks the 25th anniversary of
a landmark discovery in cosmology on the
23rd of April 1992 NASA unveiled the
picture painted in microwave light this
was the first image of the Cosmic
Microwave Background the afterglow of
the Big Bang it revealed what the
universe looked like shortly after its
birth the universe's baby picture John
mother was one of the key
astrophysicists behind this image his
interest in the microwave background
went back to his student years when he
was hunting for a thesis topic and I
looked around and I found a project
which was to build a apparatus to go up
on a high-altitude balloon so that was
my main thesis project and we built it
and it did not work and then I got a job
at NASA so I said to my new boss well
you know my thesis project didn't work
but we should try it in outer space so
that became the cosmic background
Explorer satellite the microwave
background had first been spotted back
in 1964 but no one had been able to
precisely measure it let alone map how
it varied across the sky this new
satellite Coby the cosmic microwave
background Explorer would shed new light
on its properties but developing Kobe
took 15 years and huge efforts the Coby
satellite took about 1500 people to
build you know when we started the Kobe
mission people still were designing a
NASA satellites with pencils and big
pieces of paper but all this work paid
off the first major discovery from Kobe
arrived just weeks after launch in early
1990 it was not yet a map but an
analysis of the bands of light the
spectrum that make up the radiation John
distinctly remembers the reaction he got
when he first showed this graph when I
put up my view graphs that showed the
spectrum of this cosmic background
radiation I didn't say anything and
within moments the entire
audience had stood up and was applauding
so I got a standing ovation for a chart
until then cosmology had earned itself a
bit of a bad reputation there were
plenty of theories but not much data to
back them up this chart was different
the data returned by the satellite was
indistinguishable from the theoretical
predictions but Kobe's most astonishing
finding was yet to come
our second great discovery was that the
universe has had and cold spots and
Greek we call them anisotropy these hot
and cold spots were first shown to the
world twenty-five years ago by John's
colleague George Smoot Coby measured
variations in the temperature of the
microwave background across the sky the
result a baby picture of the universe
when it was a mere 400,000 years old and
the image left scientists gasping yet
again so Stephen Hawking said if I
remember roughly it was the most
important scientific discovery of the
century if not of all time the map was
so important because it showed how the
primordial broth of elementary particles
had clumped into denser regions those
regions went on to form galaxies and
stars millions of years later John and
George shared the Nobel Prize for
Physics in 2006 and Kobes discoveries
made an impression on many young
scientists among them was young toddler
who had just started the job at the
European Space Agency I was a radio
astronomer who had specialized in doing
studies of our own galaxy which is from
a cosmological perspective a very nearby
object and suddenly there was this guy
talking about the very beginning of the
universe it made an impact in the sense
that this was clearly big science
young-soon started an effort to build a
European follow-up to Kobe called Planck
clearly Kobe assured in a new era people
tried to do better than Kobe and this
was one of the first attempts at that
missions like Planck could take much
sharper and more
detailed picture than Kobe's but they
also confirmed Kobe's results I was
really thrilled that we got the right
answer at the first time because in the
places where they could measure the same
that we measured the answers agreed
beautifully thanks to progress studying
the Cosmic Microwave Background
cosmology has made giant leaps it hasn't
covered everything from the universe's
age 13.8 billion years to signs of the
enigmatic dark matter so has the
microwave background given away all its
secrets there's still one wonderful
secret that we might find we're looking
for gravitational waves this is the
question at the top of cosmologists list
whether the baby picture of the universe
contains an imprint of gravitational
waves these ripples could confirm that
for a brief instant the universe
balloons from microscopic to cosmic size
a theory called inflation cosmologists
should be able to spot the imprint of
these gravitational waves by measuring
the polarization of the microwaves this
is the way the light is ordered together
so if we could make that measurement and
if it matches or does not match the
predictions and we will have learned
something about those extreme conditions
of the early universe Planck's final set
of results is due out before the end of
this year and they will include a map of
polarization so Planck might have a shot
at revealing the signature of
gravitational waves here is Yun again
clock is going to make a kind of unique
contribution to that in the sense that
it is able to measure this at the very
larger scales across the whole sky if
Planck fails to spot the signal other
teams are hot on its heels but even
after so much progress that picture from
25 years ago is still as magical as
now I still love looking at the picture
I am so thrilled that it has started off
a cosmic exploration that tells us
something about the big bang that we
never guess we could know
[Music]